sí
vamos por muy buen camino en la
construcción de esa toma del boceto que
recibimos del departamento de historias
pero antes de continuar hagamos una
pausa para explorar un detalle super
interesante que surge al combinar
operaciones en el último ejercicio
usaste el cambio de escalas y la
traslación para colocar algunos objetos
y yo puedo empezar trasladando ese
objeto 5 en x y 3 en 10 y luego cambiar
la escala con un factor de 2 pero qué
pasaría si cambió el orden y primero
modificó la escala antes de trasladarlo
en ese caso primero cambio la escala con
un factor de 2 y después lo trasladó 5
en x y 3 en g
nos queda un resultado diferente eso lo
que significa es que el orden de las
operaciones si importa cuando combinamos
traslación y cambio de escala intentamos
aplicar dos traslación es distintas la
primera por digamos 5 en equis y 3 en ye
y la segunda por 2 en equis y 4 anger y
si hago estas operaciones en otro orden
nos queda el mismo resultado así es que
al parecer el orden no importa cuando se
combinan dos traslación es cuando el
orden no importa los matemáticos dicen
que las operaciones son conmutativa
y cuando el orden si importa los
matemáticos dicen que las operaciones
son no conmutativa
las poblaciones se conmutan entre sí
porque la suma es conmutativa pero el
cambio de escalas y la traslación no
computan más adelante vamos a estudiar
la conmuta actividad con mucho más
detalle mientras tanto usa este
ejercicio para practicar este concepto